the sequel Kevin yes there we go part 2
part 2 we got some new people and using
your night school co-star Tiffany
Haddish yes so what like recommendations
what advice did you give her if anything
follow my lead
no you know I told I said this is a
great opportunity yeah this is this is
something that you can only dream for it
you know when you get an opportunity to
be in a movie like this that has this
type of following and hopefully has the
same success of course in part two
you're a part of what can be and will be
a franchise so it doesn't happen often
and I think those that do get the chance
embrace it and fall in love with it so
for me it was just about telling Tiffany
just to make sure that you breathe this
in and really embrace it and take full
advantage of what it possibly can be
that even your voices your two are great
together
no cap it's normal yes is this the
closest we're going to see Kevin Hart to
be playing a super girl I think so
inspire you to maybe get into that world
mr. hankey from South Park anyone is mr.
hankey did hit they turn mr. hankey into
a person that's that's about it you know
what it is you it's that's a different
world right that's a different thing
right so you know I just don't know what
what would be my gonna be I don't know
like I don't know the Marvel world who's
left I didn't know nothing about this
and all that so let's not see me that
I've been educated more in his last four
I can't keep track now speaking of
Marvel there's the mid-credits scene
here okay we got to talk about the rap
okay Panda oh yes yes the Panda
is this like an untapped thing with
Kevin Hart like could we see a rap I'm
giving you lots of ideas I don't like to
talk about it you know but I've dabbled
no I joked around and said that I could
possibly do it if I took the opportunity
here and
put the time in you know but then I
think I don't know if I want to do that
to the other rappers that are out there
I don't want to be the guy to go and
ruin careers because drinks is right or
left for trouble you get Drake around
first money I mean once I drop something
then people would be like oh my god
that's all I want to hear I don't want
to do that to the to the guy that have
been verified Wow you know yeah now -
you've been do some press and people
side together with Will Smith on the
Graham Norton Show yes love seen you two
together like yeah well all the comments
world do movie together like why is that
never happened with you and Will Smith
it something we've been talking about it
as in late and I think right now the
biggest thing is fighting what's right
yeah all right I think the biggest thing
right now is just finding what's right
there I know we don't want to just do a
movie to say we did a movie we wanted to
be great we want people to be able to go
oh my god I see why they took so long
I see why there was never anything
between the two of them this is all this
is it
what's that thing we need that right
behind and I think that's what we're
both very patient about you know finding
and making it yeah let's see it now are
you kids into this franchise the kids
love snowball yeah is that weird like
for them to hear their dad's voice as
this character doesn't appear again it
doesn't appear to be I mean they love it
they love it they love it it they love
it more or possibly or like the same
level as some of the other things that
they've gotten to see you know from
Jumanji from Rana through Central
Intelligence I let him see come on the
face but they love snowboarder
you